Time ticks forward in English, but did you
know in Mandarin earlier is up
and later is down?
Or that the Yucatec Maya have no word for
before or after?
These sound like the kind of fun facts you
share with a friend and move on.
But for linguists, time is at the center of
a major debate: are there languages where
time just doesn't work like we think it does?
There's a linguist who's spent his entire
career documenting and trying to understand
one language: Hopi.
After four years of fieldwork in Arizona,
on the Third Mesa, surely he has real insights
to share about every aspect of the language.
And yet in this long book he focuses on just
one: Hopi Time.
Over 600 pages of Hopi Time, with example
after example of how, just like English, Hopi
has words for time, like "later" or "temporarily".
The Hopi count days.
They use terms like "over there" as spatial
metaphors for time.
And their verbs have tenses: they can mark
the future with -ni.
Time, time, everywhere time!
Ok, so the Hopi can tell time.
What's the big deal?
Well, it must've mattered to someone, because
linguists and psychologists and people who'd
never heard a word of Hopi in their lives
grabbed the book and held it high as proof
that time was universal for humans.
And then they cursed the name of Whorf.
Whorf was wrong!
Whorf was a charlatan!
Whorf was a con man!
Hold on, what's the fuss?
Who ever said that Hopi doesn't think about
the past, present and future?
Plus who's this Whorf and why is he getting
picked on so much?
Whorf was a fire inspector.
But one with a unique hobby: Uto-Aztecan languages.
This curiosity led him Sapir, who took Whorf
under his wing.
Psst, hey, I've got some literature that'll
blow your mind.
See, Humboldt and Boas taught us how different
cultures subconsciously categorize the world
based on language.
But I think there's more.
I think people are at the mercy of language.
We're not living in the objective world, man,
we're living through our language.
Hah, what an odd idea.
But as Whorf turned to another Uto-Aztecan
language, he started to see it.
Hopi seemed so un-European to him in the way
it handled time.
There was no substance called "time".
No timeline that could be cut and counted.
No space as a metaphor for time, as if you
could move through time.
Not even a past, a present or a future tense.
The more Whorf studied Hopi, the more he concluded
that the arrow of time isn't something that
exists in our objective world.
Instead, we think about time this way because
we speak Standard Average European.
The Hopi don't share our concept of time because
they speak Hopi.
How do the Hopi live without tense?
Well, for Whorf, Hopi time is about cycles,
rituals, mental preparation for key events.
Above all, they have no objective time.
Sapir died at age 55 and Whorf joined him
a couple years later, aged 44.
But his ideas were captivating: do people
think about time
differently in different languages?
Does your language shape your concept of time?
Does the language you speak determine whether
or not time even exists for you?
These claims, from weak to strong, got the
nickname "Sapir-Whorf", which I often hear
pronounced "SA-pir Whorf".
Hopi Time became its poster child.
And an ever-growing big fish tale.
Hopi is innocent of a category for time.
No, worse, our concept of time would be incomprehensible
to them.
Better yet, the reason you have clocks and
watches is because you aren't Hopi.
Hah, and my favorite, Hopi time makes for
better family therapy than the Aristotelian
reality Western parents are stuck in.
So now do you see the power of these 600 pages
spent vanquishing Whorf
and mainstreaming Hopi?
Linguists had had enough.
Many of them wanted to focus on what made
language universal and innate to all of us.
Stop parading Hopi around as an exotic oddity.
We all think the same way, we just express
ourselves with a little linguistic flair.
So then, time is time is time.
It's settled.
Not quite.
Dot-dot-dot.
Years after Hopi Time, researchers claimed
they'd found new evidence showing Whorf was
right about time all along.
Like this set of experiments playing on the
difference between how English and Mandarin
speakers use space to talk about time.
"Earlier" is to your left and "later" to your
right in English, but in Mandarin things get
vertical: "earlier" is up and "later" down.
Even though these experiments were conducted
entirely in English, native Mandarin speakers
were quicker to answer simple questions about
earlier or later after being primed with vertical
cues, while native English speakers were faster
after horizontal cues.
Thinking about time, it seemed, was shaped
by language.
The masses were intrigued, myself included.
Someone passed me a link to it in my work inbox years ago,
and I wasn't even with linguists.
But in the comments of my old video about
Whorf, a researcher did mention having trouble
replicating these results.
From what I've read since then, that commenter
isn't alone.
Still, it was just one of the many Whorf-like
effects that kept making the news, some from
scientific tests in the lab, others from fieldwork
on the ground.
So in the Central Andes, there's a language
spoken by millions called Aymara.
In Aymara, your nayra, your "eye" is in front
of you, and your qhipa, your "back"
is behind you.
That's normal, but this isn't.
When talking about time, the Aymara speak
as if they face the past, but they have their
backs to the future.
They even point behind their backs to gesture
into the future.
So their eyes are exactly where your eyes
are,
but their past is not where your past is.
Rare.
Unique.
But there's something else about Aymara...
and Hopi.
At second glance, some linguists tell us both of them are best viewed as tenseless.
Wait, there are timeless languages out there?
Well, kind of.
Tenseless.
It's not as odd as it first sounds.
We already know of languages that are uncontroversially
tenseless.
Take Yucatec Maya.
Not only are they missing a past, present
and future tense, they even lack words like
"before", "until" and "after".
How in the world do they talk about time?
Well, strategies.
Complex strategies like context and aspect.
It could make a fun followup to dig into the mechanics of
how tenseless languages talk about time.
But good luck proving any of this makes them experience time
in a fundamentally different way.
Yucatec speakers do fine in experiments about
linear time, and any effects are subtle.
See, if you read the research and not the
breaking headlines, "strong" ideas of language
determining time, those are out.
Any ongoing debates are about subtler influences.
In the end, languages do talk about time differently,
but it's harder to get speakers to behave
differently based on their language.
But I'll level with you.
I get the sense that trivia about time and
tenses was never the point.
Hopi time became a mascot for a grander idea:
linguistic relativity.
Or as Sapir put it, different societies live
in distinct worlds, not merely the same world
with different labels attached.
That's an idea I suspect we'll run into again
in the future.
Until then, stick around and subscribe for
language!